Salut ! Aujourd'hui c'est la sixième vidéo sur le Rubik's Cube.
C'est-à-dire, c'est la dernière. En tout cas concernant la méthode de résolution.
Je vous avais promis quelque chose le jour 1. C'est qu'en 5 formules et en 2 minutes grand maximum, vous réussissiez à résoudre ce Rubik's Cube.
C'est notre objectif commun et on est en trian de l'atteindre.
J'avais promis 5 formules. J'ai déjà cramé les 5. On a déjà vu 5 formules ensemble.
C'est pour ça qu'on va reprendre une formule qu'on connaît déjà.
La fameuse formule:
Droite Haut, Droite inversée, Haut, Droite Haut Haut (H²), Droite inversée, Haut Haut (H²)
La seule chose c'est qu'on ne va pas l'appliquer toute seule. Quand on va s'en servir, on va coller directement la même formule, mais 100% inversée.
La seule chose qui ne bougera pas c'est le H².
Parce qu'un carré est toujours positif.
Donc, qu'on le déplace deux fois dans le sens horaire, ou deux fois dans le sens antihoraire, ça reviendrait en fait à faire un 180°.
Que je fasse deux déplacements de ce sens,
ou deux déplacements dans ce sens là,
je reviens forcément dans la même position.
Donc on se sert du: DH /D H DH² /D H²
et directement derrière, on fait: Droite inversée, Haut inversé, Droite, Haut inversé, Droite inversé, Haut carré, Droite, Haut carré.
Ca parait barbare mais d'une part vous connaissez la première formule, donc vous connaissez la deuxième puisque c'est la même mais inversée.
Et d'autre part, vous allez voir que dans les doigts c'est tout à fait naturel. Et c'est pour ça que je vais passer derrière la caméra pour vous faire voir.
Le but du jeu ça va être de manipuler les coins, sans les bouger de place,
pour pouvoir les positionner dans le bon sens.
Vous aurez à appliquer cette double formule plusieurs fois, peut-être une fois, deux fois, trois fois, quatre fois...
Mais au bout du compte, sans avoir à réfléchir, vous allez terminer le Rubik's Cube tout en protégeant tout ce qui a déjà été fait.
Je le prends dans n'importe quel sens.
Et j'applique la formule, celle qu'on connaît déjà.
Droite
Haut
Droite inversée
Droite
Haut carré
Droite inversée
Et maintenant je réapplique la même formule mais inversée.
Haut inversé
Droite
Droite inversée
Haut carré
Droite
Et regardez ce qu'il vient de se passer, c'est magnifique. Le coin s'est positionné dans le bon sens, sans avoir bougé de place et on a préservé tout le reste.
Quand on applique cette double formule, ça bouge les deux coins qui sont à gauche.
Ca ne change rien sur les deux coins qui sont à droite.
Donc je vais juste retourner comme ça, pour réappliquer la formule.
La double formule, moi je sais d'expérience, à ce stade là, qu'il va falloir que je l'applique encore deux fois.
Droite
Haut
Droite inversée
Droite
Haut carré
Droite inversée
Haut carré.
Haut inversé
Droite
Droite inversé
Haut carré
Droite
Haut carré.
Je vais encore appliquer pour la dernière fois, la double formule.
Donc se sera la troisième et dernière fois que je la fais.
C'est parti.
Vous avez vu qu'en terme de mouvement c'est très très facile à se l'imprégner dans le corps.
Au premier coup, à la première formule, on part comme ça,
et au deuxième coup, on part comme ça.
Mais bon, on papote, on papote, mais qu'est-ce qu'il vient surtout de se passer ?
On vient de finir une bonne fois pour toute ce Rubik's Cube !
Le Rubik's Cube est enfin fini après 6 jours.
Et je vous avez promis qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres formules et c'est le cas. C'est juste la même mais inversée, donc ça ne compte pas comme une nouvelle formule.
Retenez bien en tout cas que quand vous l'avez dans les mains, ce sont ces deux angles là qui vont bouger.
Vous préservez ça.
Demain, je ferai une dernière vidéo sur le Rubik's Cube.
Ce sera une vidéo un petit peu récap' et surtout avec un bonus à la fin, une petite figure qu'on peut faire avec le Rubik's Cube pour s'amuser !
Parce que le Rubik's Cube c'est la déconne !
Mais merci beaucoup ! Merci à vous d'avoir suivi toutes ces vidéos sur le Rubik's Cube.
Si ça vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce en l'air pour le signifier.
N'hésitez pas aussi à vous abonner à la chaine.
Vous pouvez aussi laisser un petit commentaire.
Si vous êtes intéressé par cette série de Rubik's Cube, sachez que j'ai tourné ces vidéos au YouTube Space à Paris, au mois d'avril.
J'ai fait les sept vidéos d'un coup, donc y compris celle que je vais faire là, juste après.
Puisque comme je me suis lancé le défi de faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an, j'ai peur du jour où je vais tomber malade.
Et donc si vous êtes en train de regarder ça, c'est que soit j'ai était malade, soit on est au mois de juillet.
Et si on est mi-juillet, ça veut dire que je suis en vacances au Mexique, et que j'ai programmé ces vidéos là avant de partir.
Rendez-vous demain à 17H pour un dernier récap' sur le Rubik's Cube, je vous donnerai les dernières astuces,
et un petit bonus pour une figure que vous pouvez faire avec.
Entrainez vous bien. Je suis ravi que vous sachiez maintenant faire un Rubik's Cube.
Rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !